Hollywood had its biggest year ever in
2018
despite streaming sites like Netflix and
Hulu staking a claim on its territory
but thanks to this year's crop of
amazing films that box office record
might not last for long
here are the best movies of 2019 so far
if there were any concerns that writer
director Jordan peels Academy
award-winning debut get out was a fluke
they were quickly laid to rest by us in
the film a family is taunted by evil
versions of themselves and it's highly
unsettling stop critics were
particularly stunned by Lapita Iago's
performance the lamplight review noted
that performances and genre pieces are
often dismissed and disregarded but make
no mistake
neon goes work in us is some of the very
best of her career critics were also
impressed by peels death mixing of
comedic elements with nerve jingling
terror a review and splice today
succinctly summed up his achievement
claiming that us combines masterful
visuals with dense storytelling and a
half-dozen instant classic sequences and
it's scary as hell right now writer
director nia decosta only has a handful
of credits to her name but thanks to
little woods her insanely self-assured
debut feature that's about to change and
hurry decosta wrote the screenplay for
Littlewoods
a story about two troubled sisters one
of them is a convicted drug runner who's
trying to get through her last few days
of probation unfortunately she's forced
to return to the drug trade after her
mother dies leaving behind a hefty
mortgage on the family home I know
you're selling the cab
appreciate losing customers because you
decided to get back in the business
by casting Tessa Thompson in the lead
role of Olli decosta nabbed one of the
hottest actresses working today her
performance was roundly praised with
descriptors like towering and riveting
being par for the course but it's the
Costas keen eye for small details and
sweeping cinematic shots that really had
the critics singing her praises and
she's just getting started - in fact
she's all set to update the horror
classic Candyman for producer Jordan
Peele and that should definitely be a
sight to see there's been more written
about Avengers endgame than any other
cinematic release in recent memory but
the fact that it's a really good film is
often buried beneath the reams of press
and publicity Avengers endgame is
brimming with jaw-dropping action a
surprising amount of humor and the kind
of emotional resonance that's sure to
captivate diehard fans and casual
moviegoers alike you trust me I do many
critics Pegg debentures endgame is one
of the greatest acts of fanservice ever
committed to film and while familiarity
with the MCU is pretty much required to
make it a complete viewing experience
the movie is even more impressive for
how well it works on its own terms
flick Philosopher's enthused that
Avengers endgame is a miraculous blend
of grief and humor big bold brash then
sneakily meta sift pops stated in no
uncertain terms just how much the film
rocks writing that the word epic gets
thrown around so much that we've
forgotten what it actually means this
movie is here to remind you meanwhile
the London Evening Standard apparently
couldn't say enough good things about
the film writing that the only
complaints about Avengers endgame is
that it raises the bar so high that
there may well never be a superhero
movie to match it the John wig series
has never aspired to be high arts but it
just might be the purest adrenaline
delivery device in the history of modern
cinema three films in director chats the
house key and star Keanu Reeves have
really perfected the formula John wig
chapter 3 Parabellum gives diehard
action fans exactly what they came for
and then some
it's easy to see why Reeves is
beleaguered hitman is swiftly becoming
an icon let it suffice to say the actors
committed performance since the
housekeys sharp direction had critics
applauding the third entry in the series
Scotland's The Herald wrote Reeves has
charisma to burn by the
time to hours are up quick is once again
living up to the Latin in the title
desiring peace but preparing for war
fetch John fetch in its own highly
positive review the movie blog said John
week three is a buffet of action that
only leaves you wanting more flickering
myth was just as enthusiastic writing
that where most franchises begin to
stumble around movie three John wick
Chapter three is the best in this highly
entertaining series the rom-com genre
isn't exactly known for its inventive
and intriguing storylines but thanks to
a whip-smart screenplay long shots is
something truly special Seth Rogen stars
as Fred Flor ski a journalist who ends
up reconnecting with his childhood
babysitter Charlotte field played by
Charlize Theron it turns out Charlotte's
becoming a highly powerful political
figure in fact she's gearing up for a
presidential run when Charlotte
impulsively appoints Fred to be her
speechwriter events take a decidedly
romantic turn the chemistry between the
two leads is really something to marvel
at as you can see for yourself
hooked up with my fair share of world
leaders to critics absolutely loved the
film with the Daily Herald gushing what
are the odds that this zany rom-com
would turn out to be the funniest
crowd-pleaser of 2019 so far The Mail on
Sunday was equally effusive in its
praise this is surely one of the most
welcomed surprises of the cinematic year
with Jonathan Levine's enjoyable film
showing that unorthodox casting
combinations can work and that there is
still life in the romantic comedy bara
an updated family-friendly take on the
king arthur legend the kid who would be
king had a lot of things going for it
right out of the gate it's the second
directorial effort from Joe Cornish who
helmed the excellent sci-fi comedy
attacked the block and co-wrote the
original script for marvels ant-man the
film's casting is pure genius with Sir
Patrick Stewart as the wizard Merlin and
Rebecca Ferguson as the evil enchantress
Morgana Lewis Ashbourne circus stars as
a British schoolboy who stumbles upon
the mystical sword Excalibur and must
embrace his identity as a leader
unfortunately the kid who would be king
was a commercial failure for Fox but it
certainly scored big with critics The
Guardian said the film is sentimental in
all the right places and impossible to
dislike meanwhile one room with a view
praised cornices Direction claiming that
delivers a sword & Sworcery adventure
with the intelligence and sensitivity
that kids films deserve but do not
always receive hopefully the film's poor
box-office performance won't diminish
hornish's future prospects he's got
talent to spare and he's proven to be
highly skilled at juggling comedic and
dramatic elements and the service of his
wholly unique visions in order to
succeed Captain Marvel had to give us a
compelling origin story and set the
scene for avengers endgame indie
filmmakers Anna Boden and Ryan fleck
rose to the occasion brilliantly and
their first big-budget tentpole movie is
supremely entertaining thanks to an
incredible script and a particularly
brilliant lead performance from Oscar
winner brie Larson the film is an
absolute triumph critics commended
Larson for bringing a strong sense of
fun and swagger to the role of Carol
Danvers and many reviewers praised the
on-screen chemistry between Larson and
samuel l.jackson who portrays a
digitally d aged Nick Fury how long you
plan to be in town oh I'll be out of
your hair as soon as I track down the
scrolls that are infiltrating your
planet Scrolls reviewers also loved Ben
Mendelsohn's performance as a scroll
warrior Talos the main edge absolutely
loved the film noting how Captain Marvel
could have floundered under the
storytelling load it was asked the
shoulder but instead manages to mostly
soar giving us a fun and engaging
narrative some decent gags and some
solid action set-pieces along with a
killer 90 soundtrack
Shazam might just be the warmest
friendliest goofiest superhero film ever
Zachary Levi completely sells the notion
of a fourteen-year-old inhabiting a
superheros body bringing a wide-eyed
wonder to the role your puns does your
con stars and your phones charged well
you think you better
Oh critics were quick to embrace the
film with the Wall Street Journal
writing that what Shazam lacks most
obviously is gravitas and grimness also
bleakness darkness and relentless self
seriousness in other words it's terrific
fun other critics noted that director
David F Sandburg masterfully juggled the
film's humorous emotional and
action-packed sequences and some
reviewers were excited about what this
could mean for the future of the DC
extended universe what's the long boldly
proclaiming that Shazam is a sign that
it is at last ready to compete with
Marvel 2014's the lego movie was a
surprise hit and definitely one of the
best animated films of the year in fact
if we're being honest it's better than
any film based on building block toys
has any right to be this year's the lego
movie to the second part saw the return
of the first film stellar voice cast
including Chris Pratt's Elizabeth Banks
Will Ferrell and Will Arnett it also
added talent like Tiffany Haddish and
Jason Momoa who reprised his role as
Aquaman from last year's live-action
blockbuster film Inc where we had
nothing but good things to say about
lego movie 2 the second parts writing
that it's a rare film a perfectly
crafted sequel that expands on the world
and mythology of its predecessor but
stands firmly on its own little lego
lakes dreamworks is How to Train Your
Dragon franchise has garnered the kind
of critical praise and box office
receipts normally reserved for Pixar
offerings and there's a very good reason
for that
each of the films are technically
accomplished and imbued with a depth of
storytelling and emotion that's highly
uncommon in kids animated features the
2010 original and 2014's How to Train
Your Dragon 2 raked in over a billion
dollars worldwide it took five long
years for the trilogy capper the hidden
world to finally arrive and guess what
the wait was well worth it because the
film is really good critics thought so
too
Laramie movie scope wrote that it's a
nice story
combined with marvelous animation which
has only gotten more sophisticated and
effective over the years thanks to
advances in technology meanwhile the New
York Post proclaimed that the movie
could easily be called how to end your
trilogy over the years animation housed
Leica Studios has released quite a few
films and they've all been highly unique
there's the 2009 hit Coraline 2012's
ParaNorman and the well-received 2016
fantasy film Kubo and the two strings
for this year's missing link the studio
recruited ParaNorman director Chris
Butler and a talented voice cast
featuring Hugh Jackman Zach Galifianakis
and Zoe Saldana it's the story of a
bigfoot-like creature who enlist famous
explorers to lead him on a quest to find
his relatives take me there I give you
my word the action-packed narrative and
sweet humor really won over reviewers
but the eye-popping stop-motion
animation is undoubtedly missing links
ace-in-the-hole the website rave claimed
missing link continues to prove not only
like us visual mastery but also the
studio's commitment to telling
emotionally resonant stories consequence
of sound was equally generous in its
praise as with so many leica films
you'll come for the breathtaking
animation and you'll leave both
enchanted and surprised by the big
beating heart beneath it even the less
effusive reviews couldn't help but gush
over the film's visual style although
the Washington Post claimed the film was
missing something
it also assured readers that the movie
is visually stunning with well realized
characters and humor that really does
work
sadly the film's lackluster box office
performance might not be enough to keep
the financially troubled animation house
afloat but as you can see the film is
absolutely beautiful to look at and we
strongly recommend watching the film if
you haven't already
I would be bad time oh no three more of
them we could build a random the Toy
Story series offered up three
near-perfect animated films in the space
of 15 years and after a flawless capper
in Toy Story 3 and a 9 year gap fans
could be forgiven for being a bit wary
of Toy Story 4 but Pixar did it once
again
fielding a fourth entry in the saga of
Woody Buzz in the gang that's every bit
as heartfelt lovingly animated and
hilarious as its predecessors
Matthew Norman of the London Evening
Standard wrote Toy Story 4 is so good
it's criminal the legislation it flouts
is the law of diminishing returns which
governs movies with numbers after their
names
the film's accolades were many and
covered every aspect of its production
from the animation to the story to its
treatment of its new characters NBC
News's Annie bundle wrote everyone gets
time to tell their story whether it's
Duke kaboom or Buzz Lightyear perhaps
the highest praise delivered by Reno
news and reviews Bob Grimm is it the
last one oh come on
just keep making these movies forever
2019 has been something special for
Marvel Studios with three critically
acclaimed billion dollar-plus grossing
hits an unprecedented feat to bring it
close to the three phase infinity saga
the saga concluded with the sweet
action-packed coda spider-man far from
home
the vers live-action Spidey vehicle to
ever break a billion at the global box
office
critics were taken with how the film
played with the conventions of a genre
continually up ending audience
expectations especially with respect to
its alleged secondary hero the devious
Mysterio played by Jake Gyllenhaal whose
performance garnered widespread praise
as did star Tom Holland the spider-man
series remains a favorite among Marvel
fans thanks to director John Watson's
distinctive John Hughes like tone for
all of its butt-kicking spectacle many
critics praised it as simply a
delightful coming-of-age comedy which
just happened to also feature some of
the most jaw-dropping post-credit scenes
the MCU has yet offered producer Sam
Raimi and director Alexander Asha have a
highly admirable horror pedigree and
Krall sported a unique premise trapped
in her father's home during a massive
hurricane with blood waters on the rise
a woman gets some unexpected company in
the form of some hungry
the flick milks this premise for all
it's worth and critics generally agreed
that the result was a white-knuckle
fright fest rich with tension and chills
lead Kaya Scodelario is praised for her
energetic performance helping to whisk
the film along from one terrifying
set-piece to the next as many of the
flicks champions noted it's tough to go
wrong in the hands of skilled filmmakers
with all of these ingredients at their
disposal the movie blogs Emmanuel
noisette wrote when you combine a
natural disaster scary predators and
confined spaces all through a personal
human lens you have a solid film on your
hands while the movie had its requisite
share of detractors its defenders noted
that crawl delivered exactly what it
promised Peter vonderhaar of Houston
press wrote if you go into crawl hoping
to see a woman in probably outswim large
pissed-off
reptiles or watch ATM thieves get
messily devoured you're in for one of
the most enjoyable theatrical
experiences of the year check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]